creo que lo que hemos estado
desarrollando se está poniendo muy
interesante en el primer vídeo hicimos
un diagrama espacio-temporal desde mi
marco de referencia de verdad y gráfica
mostra gec torias en ese diagrama y
luego hablamos de nuestra amiga verdad
que se encuentra al tiempo de igual a
cero verdad se halla justo por arriba de
mí es decir en x igual a 0 y se mueve a
una velocidad relativa de la mitad de la
velocidad de la luz verdad y entonces
aquí tenemos su trayectoria verdad
quiere decir que al tiempo de igual a
cero se encuentra en x igual a 0 es
decir está justo sobre de mí pero
después de un segundo ella se encuentra
a 1.5 por 10 a la 8 metros después de
dos segundos ella se encuentra se
encuentra justamente a 3 por 10 a la 8
metros y así sucesivamente y entonces
este es la trayectoria vista en este
diagrama de espacio tiempo y finalmente
dijimos que había una serie de naves
verdad
que se movían con la misma velocidad
relativa a mí verdad entonces ente igual
a cero aquí se encuentra una nave es
decir se halla a tres por diez a la ocho
metros de distancia de donde yo me
encontraba entre igual a cero verdad
entonces para el tiempo te iguala uno
por ejemplo pensemos justo en este punto
ente igual a uno bueno pues vamos a dar
justo las coordenadas verdad ente igual
a un segundo vamos a tener que éste se
encuentra en la posición x de 4.5 por 10
a la 8 metros muy bien esta sería su
posición en x en mi marco de referencia
verdad pero cuál sería su posición
digamos en este diagrama en el marco de
referencia de mi amiga y bueno esto fue
en mi marco de referencia verdad
simplemente teníamos que trazar una
línea vertical para encontrar la
posición x y una línea horizontal para
encontrar el tiempo verdad pero si lo
hacemos en él
en el marco de referencia de mi amiga
nos fijamos de forma horizontal hasta
llegar al eje de prima que es el eje de
el eje vertical podríamos pensarlo así
de mi amiga verdad y tendríamos que
bajar de forma paralela a dicho eje
hasta interceptar este digamos este eje
verdad que sería el eje x prima y
entonces podemos ver que su coordenada t
prima sería justamente la misma verdad
un segundo mientras que la coordenada x
prima sería de 3 por 10 a la 8 metros
verdad tenemos que bajar de forma
paralela al eje de prima muy bien y esto
tiene sentido verdad en realidad es
porque se mantienen a la misma distancia
por tener la misma velocidad relativa y
por lo tanto siempre se encontrará a 3
por 10 a la 8 metros de distancia de mi
amiga entonces la pregunta ahora es cómo
corden como convertimos las coordenadas
x por ejemplo aquí vamos a poner la
coordenada
xy aquí vamos a poner la coordenada x
prima
un poquito más más claro la coordenada x
prima verdad como convertimos de una a
la otra y bueno podemos ver en este
ejemplo que x prima siempre va a ser más
chico que la coordenada x y esto tiene
sentido porque x prima es estacionario
desde el digamos desde el marco de
referencia de mi amiga pero x avanza en
mi marco de referencia verdad la nave se
va alejando a medida que el tiempo
avanza entonces si pensamos en esta
diferencia en la diferencia entre x y
equis prima pues esa diferencia o esa
discrepancia sería la velocidad relativa
por el tiempo entonces vamos a ir
escribiendo todo esto aquí podemos ver
que su coordenada t prima en realidad
siempre va a ser la misma que la que la
coordenada t mientras que la coordenada
x prima
x menos b porque donde ves la velocidad
relativa y t es el tiempo entonces en
este ejemplo particular en ese punto
particular tenemos 3 x 10 a la 8 sería
igual a 4.5 por 10 a la 8 verdad
simplemente estoy sustituyendo el valor
de x y el valor de x prima y podemos ver
que en efecto esta vez 4.5 por 10 a la 8
menos la velocidad verdad que es es 1.5
por 10 a la 8 por el tiempo que en este
caso sería 1 y por supuesto aquí no he
puesto las unidades pero si uno
sustituye con metros o metros sobre
segundos o segundos verdad todo todo
funciona verdad el punto es que
obtenemos de este lado 3 por 10 a la 8
entonces espero que con todo esto ya te
familiarices con estos planos ordenados
encimados verdad y ahora de lo que
quiero hablar es de lo que ocurre lo que
le ocurre al fotón que yo emití
de igual a cero verdad que tiene
justamente la velocidad de la luz verdad
aquí está la trayectoria que representa
a ese fotón es esta trayectoria podemos
ver que después de un segundo ha
recorrido 3 por 10 a la 8 metros después
de dos segundos ha recorrido 6 por 10 a
la 8 metros y después de tres segundos
habrá recorrido 9 por 10 a la 8 metros
verdad entonces esa sería la trayectoria
de nuestro desde el fotón que yo emití
al tiempo de igual a cero verdad pero
veamos cómo se ve ese fotón desde el
marco de referencia de mi amigo entonces
veamos aquí por ejemplo para este punto
voy a remarcar lo con verde para este
punto te digamos para el tiempo te
iguala 2 segundos
tendremos que su coordenada de prima
será también 2 segundos
segundos pero su coordenada x prima será
3 por 10 a la 8 metros verdad es decir
resulta ser que en su marco de
referencia a ese fotón que yo emití le
llevo dos segundos llegar a tres por 10
a la 8 metros es decir como si la
velocidad de ese fotón fuera 1.5 por 10
a la 8 metros sobre segundo verdad en el
marco de referencia de mi amiga verdad
entonces esto tiene tiene sentido desde
el punto de vista newtoniano o galilea
no de hecho estas son transformaciones
galileanas verdad estas de aquí son
transformaciones galileanas puedes
pensarlo también de esta forma por
ejemplo que si vamos en un auto a 60
kilómetros por hora y vemos a otro auto
que va a 65 kilómetros por hora parece
que en realidad se mueve a 5 kilómetros
por hora desde nuestro punto de vista
verdad así el fotón sería más
lento en este caso para ella verdad
similarmente vamos a suponer que nuestra
amiga también tiene una linterna verdad
aquí tiene una linterna y también emiten
un fotón verdad al tiempo de igual a
cero entonces esto esto resulta ser
vamos a dibujar el diagrama o la
trayectoria para ese fotón verdad
entonces él el fotón al tiempo de igual
a cero se encuentra también en x igual a
cero pero después de un segundo se
encuentra a tres por 10 a la 8 metros en
el marco de referencia de mi amiga
verdad entonces tendríamos que bajar de
forma paralela al eje de prima después
de dos segundos ella debería encontrarse
en 6 por 10 a la 8 metros verdad esto
sería aquí en el marco de referencia de
mi amiga entonces podríamos simplemente
trazar la trayectoria correspondiente a
ese fotón emitido por mi amiga
entonces más o menos se ve algo así más
o menos sería la trayectoria en este
diagrama espacio-temporal verdad y esto
es bastante interesante porque desde mi
punto de vista su fotón va mucho más
rápido que la velocidad de la luz verdad
y esto en principio tiene sentido en
digamos desde el punto de vista
newtoniano o galilea no pero resulta ser
que no es lo que se observa en la
naturaleza cada vez que algo que
predecimos y que no se observa en la
naturaleza significa que nuestro
entendimiento del mundo no está completo
porque resulta que sin importar qué
marco de referencia inercial tomemos
verdad la velocidad de la luz siempre
debe ser 3 por 10 a la 8 metros sobre
segundo verdad mientras que eso no es lo
que ocurre en estos día gramas así que
sabemos de nuestras observaciones del
universo que cuando mi amiga viera el
fotón que yo emití este fotón que yo
emití debería verlo
a 3 por 10 a la 8 metros sobre segundo y
de igual forma yo no debería verás un
fotón más rápido que la velocidad de la
luz
de esta forma aquí vemos cómo es que
nuestra forma newtoniana oga liliana de
ver el mundo se viene abajo y esto es
muy emocionante necesitamos otra forma
de conceptualizar las cosas o podríamos
decirlo así otras formas de visualizar
los de los diagramas espacio-temporales
para los distintos marcos de referencia